طائرات بدون طيار تابعة للبحرية الأوكرانية بالقرب من ساحل شبه جزيرة
القرم المحتلة تقول KF إنها ضربت
سفينتين إنزال روسيتين مما أدى إلى تدمير
السفن، وهي ضربة رئيسية لبحرية بوتين.
قالت المخابرات العسكرية الأوكرانية لشبكة
CNN وفقًا لمعلومات محدثة
إنها غرقت ولا يمكن إصلاحها،
ويقول إن المعدات المدرعة كانت أيضًا
دمرت على وجه الخصوص مركبة قتال مشاة على متن
إحدى سفن الإنزال. ولا تستطيع شبكة CNN
التحقق بشكل مستقل من الحادث ولم
تعلق موسكو عليه حتى الآن، لكن
كيف يقول إنهم يواصلون
الضغط على القوات الروسية،
وتقول أوكرانيا إن قواتها ضربت هذه
السفينة مؤخرًا.  في ميناء كيرتش
بعدة صواريخ كروز
وتعلن المخابرات العسكرية مسؤوليتها عن
اغتيال قائد سابق للميليشيا الموالية لروسيا
في مدينة
لوهانسك المحتلة على الأرض على الرغم من أن الأمر لا
يزال صعبًا، حيث
يعترف الأوكرانيون بأنهم بالكاد يحرزون أي
تقدم حتى  عندما أطلقوا هذه
اللقطات بطائرة بدون طيار والتي تزعم أنها تظهر
خسائر فادحة في الدروع الروسية بالقرب من بلدة
ديفا، أنا متأكد من أننا سنحقق النجاح،
فالأمر صعب بينما يستمر كلا الجانبين
في استنزاف القوى البشرية مع القليل من الأراضي
وتغيير الأيدي، ويبدو أن الروس حريصون على
الحصول على مقاتلين سابقين  مما كانت عليه
شركة فاغنر العسكرية الخاصة التي كان يقودها
ييج بران الذي قُتل في
حادث تحطم طائرة في أغسطس في ساحة
المعركة، ينشر الرجل القوي رمضان
قديروف هذا الفيديو الذي يظهر
قواته وهي تتدرب مع
مرتزقة روس، وبعضهم يحمل بقع فاجنر على زيهم الرسمي.
يمارس كل شيء بدءًا
من اعتداءات المشاة وحتى
عمليات الإجلاء الطبي الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين بنفسه يتفقد
العربات العسكرية ذات الكثبان الرملية في القيادة الجنوبية للجيش الروسي
في روستوف على نهر الدون مع
وزير دفاعه وكبير جنرالاته،
هذا هو المبنى نفسه الذي
احتلته مقاتلات فاجنر خلال فترة المجموعة
القصيرة.  تمرد في يونيو دعا بوتين منذ فترة
طويلة إلى عودة مقاتلي فاجنر
إلى
ساحة المعركة، واليوم لديك
الفرصة لمواصلة خدمتك
لروسيا من خلال توقيع عقد مع
وزارة الدفاع، كما يقول أو غيرها من
وكالات إنفاذ القانون أو الأمن أو
العودة
إلى الوطن الروس  يزعم أن مئات
الآلاف قد سجلوا بالفعل
للقتال في أوكرانيا، بينما تتعهد كيا بالصمود في
مكانها بغض النظر عن عدد الجنود الذين
ترسلهم موسكو من قاعدة سي إن إن
برلين